some well I'm doing this let me just
confirm what Rafael said that I was
asked to speak on the rather expansive
set of topics of black holes firewalls
and chaos and I was strategic and have a
counterproposal that I would only speak
on two of these topics thank you black
holes and in chaos I have a strategic
advantage though in that I think I have
agreed to moderate the discussion this
afternoon and since firewalls are
actually a very puzzling very
interesting argument that well has
propelled a lot of the work in this
field I think it would be appropriate if
we have a little bit of a discussion
this afternoon about them I am happy to
see that one of the offers of this
Baroness ahmed al miera is sitting in
the front row and you should think about
maybe saying a few words this afternoon
so um I'll continue with this list of
if I don't you made it clear that
Stanford it's not just where you work I
will make that clear I will make that
extremely clear
following on Rafael's point as might be
obvious from this virtually everything
that I know about black holes and chaos
I learned from my collaborator Douglas
Stanford who's sitting in the front row
doing our to your plus ongoing
collaboration so I'm glad that he can be
here it's not the play it is the place
where I work but it's also the name of
my collaborator all right so what I am
going to talk about is black holes and
chaos and this is a subject that has to
do with a system that was formed a
rather small part of Patrick stock the
subject of thermal systems and we'll
have to define what we mean I'm not sure
we'll actually have something really
satisfying but as a start these are
systems that are described by a thermal
density matrix eyes by the partition
function and if we want to talk about
pure States we can imagine that this
density matrix is purified by this
two-sided state that Patrick talk about
that we might call the the thermal field
double state so again one of the
marvelous things about this a DSC ft
correspondence or in a more general
framework that gauge gravity duality is
that these thermal states also have an
elegant geometrical dual their dual in
the bulk is a black hole which after all
is a thermal system it has an entropy it
has a temperature given by Hawking
radiation and it corresponds quite
precisely to a thermal state in the
Boundary quantum mechanical field theory
and just to illustrate a few pieces of
that let's imagine that this is the
boundary field theory here I'm
straightening out the the circle that
Patrick drew or we can imagine this is a
very small piece of that circle and this
is this radial direction the extra
holographic direction and then in a
black hole geometry you have a certain
radius the horizon radius at which
things get interesting my joint into
this other side of the world or you
might fall into the black hole
if we then imagine computing
entanglement entropy obtained a small
region we would form this Ryu tacky nagi
surface as Patrick discussed and it
would work just about the same as it
worked in ordinary ADF space with no
thermal excitation let's imagine this is
one spatial dimension and this is length
L we would find this characteristic
roughly speaking an area law because
it's a conformal field theory of michael
like log l but if we took a longer
interval the surface schematically drops
all the way in hugs the horizon till it
comes back out and we find that the
length of this segment the analog of its
area is proportional to L so for this
surface we find that the entanglement
entropy is proportional to l l is the
volume here and so this is a volume law
of entanglement so the volume law of
entanglement of thermal states
corresponds to having a horizon in the
spoke geometry and in fact the entropy
is proportional to this length over for
G Newton which in these large n gauge
theories that are often the duel is
proportional to N squared L G Newton is
like 1 over m square yes but people from
a fifth here you should simply log out
right so no only if it's a thermal state
in the conformal field theory it's a
little in the vacuum of the conformal
field theory it's log L so I'm thinking
of a highly excited state in the
conformal field there and so it's
precisely there that you see vol volume
law entanglement right and the picture
the geometrical picture again is very
beautiful you're hugging this horizon
and this of course corresponds to fact
that the entropy of a black hole which
is the given by the area of its horizon
/ for G Newton which motivated this ryu
takiye nagi proposal is that that this
hot bekenstein hawking entropy is just
the area of the
riesel so that's one point the thermal
systems have more than volume law
entanglement okay they thermal eyes
whatever that means you know roughly
speaking what it means is you take a
rather special state they evolve
chaotically in such a way toward a more
typical state that has volume law
entanglement entropy looks looks thermal
okay approximates expectation values
given in this thermal density this is a
very difficult phenomenon to study using
standard techniques in quantum systems
or quantum field theory it's time
dependent the systems that fertilize
best are strongly interacting it's hard
you know it's been a big problem okay
and one of the many great things about
this gauge gravity duality is that
certain aspects of thermalization are
laid out for us very clearly and we'll
talk about some and we'll talk about
some more recent ones discussed here
depending on how far we get the first
indication is that suppose you started
from a special state let's say in the
bulk that special state corresponds with
several massive particles lying around
okay and evolve them in time typically
what happens is if you have enough of
them an energy greater than of order N
squared many N squared those massive
particles collapse and form a black hole
that's what happens in general
relativity if you watch the time
evolution of a bunch of matter it
generically collapses in forms of black
hole a black hole is a thermal state so
typical high energy states evolve to
something thermal so this thermalization
process is laid out for us is one of the
most generic basic phenomenon general
relativity stuff collapses to make a
black hole and this is one of the many
beautiful parts of this duality
thermalization is just the most obvious
thing there is yes so yes in the
boundary field theory i've been i've
made some little lives and you know in
the surface of a bigger truth in higher
dimensions a special
a candidate for this boundary theory
would be an su n gauge theory and it
would be that in in 1 plus 1 dimensions
that's not the easiest candidate but
it's that n it tells and it basically
tells you the number of degrees of
freedom in this boundary theory you have
fields that have ends that correspond to
N squared matrices you have of order N
squared fields ok so it's not surprising
the entropy sure to be of order n square
it is called see no I can't yeah but I
should but I can't ok but you're you're
you're not allowed to say I mean I'm yes
see you you just as usual Daniel you got
me off my rhythm um all right so let me
draw one of these Penrose diagrams for
that kind of collapse you might have
here's the ad s boundary this is might
be the origin you start with some matter
Oh what does it look like Mike there's a
shell of clapping at a shell but a piece
of collapsing matter it forms a
singularity and at some time during the
evolution a horizon forms horizons are
45 degree ray light rays in this diagram
and so an observer late in time this is
time looking back in to the system says
ah there's a horizon and an amidst
talking radiation the state has become
thermal so this this is a this is a good
thing another thing that we can do those
we can ask about time scales how long
does it take for this much of matter to
collapse and form a black hole and the
most quantitative thing we can do is we
can ask suppose the system has almost
formed a black hole and what is the very
latest stage is settling down so we
imagine linearizing this this evolution
a little bit away from the static case
and that's something that people in
general relativity have studied for many
years it corresponds to something called
Kwazii normal modes these are the
linearization around the solution and
Kwazii normal modes are described by a
freak
see this frequency has a real part
there's some oscillations with high
times an imaginary part and this
corresponds to the relaxation to the
pure black hole this is thermalization
the system relaxes down to the state and
so one can compute rather simply using
classical geometry what these kwasi
normal frequencies are and Omega
imaginary if the field that's relaxing
like if it's the metric or if it's some
other scalar field not too heavy that's
of order the temperature of the system
sometimes I'll write this as 1 over beta
so it's the characteristic energy scale
and if we ask her the time scale for the
system to relax it's a border of a
thermal time scale so you have this very
complicated system a strongly
interacting gauge theory that would be a
real difficult thing to study but you
solving classical general relativity
questions you can figure out the time
scale to relax now this is what you
might guess but you actually get compute
coefficients and so again this is one of
the marvels of this kind of duality yes
is going this way or can fall in things
fall into the horizon um now in the
boundary this would correspond to some
thermal correlator of some field
operator this is some field operator in
this boundary field theory in these
gauge theories this could be like the
trace of a couple matrix of a matrix
squared or something these brackets are
thermal expectation values this would go
something like e to the minus Omega
imaginary tea it might isolate with you
the real part and this corresponds to
the relaxation of this thing down to its
equilibrium value let's assume the
equilibrium value of these things as
zero yes
yes normally that's that's right that's
right and further the you might study
more complicated things thermal
expectation value of time ordered for
point functions where the ordering of
this thing is as written pretty quickly
the stuff that you throw in will relax
and as far as these later operators go
the system just looks like a black hole
so this thing looks like ww doesn't
matter what time VV + order e to the
minus Omega I things settle down
right but these quantity this is great
this is really a marvelous thing but
these kind of quantities probe I rather
preliminary kind of thermalization a
brother preliminary kind of chaos in my
roughly analogous to the kind of time in
a hot gas for a particle molecule to
undergo a few collisions what's not
being answered here is a more refined
notion of thermalization the time it is
for each degree of freedom to interact
with each other one if you will for all
the degrees of freedom to become
entangled with each other and this this
is a question that people have been
looking at recently in the context of
black holes now answers to these
questions actually grew out of quantum
information in particular studies of
attempts to make good approximations to
har random unitary operators which are
kind of the ultimate in quantum chaos
okay and the kind of approximations I'm
talking about going to the name of
approximate unitary to designs some of
the people in this room have made
important contributions to that subject
and from quantum information these ideas
were connected to the physics of black
holes by Patrick Hayden and John
Prescott and building on that too
actually these gauge gravity dualities
by tsukino and lenny Susskind and this
work of tsukino and Susskind in
particular they advance the fast
scrambling conjecture which is closely
related to this work that I hope I'll
get a chance to say a few words about
but if I back off a little bit from the
science I can say that this work is
another one of these poster children for
this connection between quantum
information quantum many-body systems
and quantum gravity here the the flow
was in this interesting direction and
maybe it's going to circle back maybe
this last paper it circled back a bit
but but I think it's a real existence
proof the real power and and advances
can come from this interconnection so so
I'm sold and
I guess if you're here you're sort of
sold also so the question is how do we
diagnose this kind of chaos and for this
I'm going to talk about some of the
notions that are described in this very
nice paper and a way of diagnosing this
chaos and I guess here the erase this
so you could this kind of chaos now it
means the weaker of the stronger the
kind of chaos were having to do with
each degree of freedom interacting with
each other okay I'm deliberately not
being more specific than that because
these things are defined by as I
described my mouth see why this thing
actually sits in home
so let's examine let's say in the
quantum system in the field theory the
time evolved operator and let's say W is
a rather simple operator it might be the
trace of a couple matrices and these
large n gauge theories or in a qubit
system it might be a single poly matrix
let's think carefully about what these
three factors mean this first factor
might correspond to time evolution
forward you evolve in time and then
after you've evolved in time you apply a
perturbation this w then you run it
backward laughs Necker what do you get
well the system was not chaotic it was a
free system basically what might happen
is this operator might move time evolved
a free thur me I'd operate it moves over
under its according to its velocity but
if there's a lot of chaos in this
Hamiltonian you take the simple operator
you time evolved ping the system that
ping makes an enormous effect so when
you make this time operator go back you
don't get close to what you started with
and in fact the operator could be very
complicated could involve the products
many many poly matrices say
so a diagnostic of chaos is to ask how
complicated this operator gets when you
go forward ping and go back how much do
you fail to cancel out the forward and
backward motion by applying a small
perturbation now a way of diagnosing how
complicated this operator is is asked
for the commutator let's say at time
zero of this operator sometimes called a
precursor in the business how big is
this comp commutator okay if this is
made of lots of poly matrices and this
is like a one poly matrice well you will
have a it will fail to commute quite a
bit keep it there no no not at all in
fact one wants to ask this question for
quite general sets of these and w's and
one can give a miracle diagnostic of the
size of this commutator by taking its
expectation value in a thermal state so
we could define for instance C of T a
number is equal to the thermal
expectation value
they get positive let's say these are
hermitian operators this makes a
positive quantity and the expectation
values in the expectation is in a
chaotic system as time increases this
number will get bigger and so at short
time typical V this this one was
completely commute so this curve might
look start small and then at some time
it might come up to its maximum value
and I'll tell you what that maximum
value we expect is in a minute and this
turn on will be a diagnostic of this
more fine-grained chaos
that's right so this is a question for a
rather generic operator you had you have
to ask sort of pick the up you know pick
an operator that's not one of these
special operators where this clicks like
what's the worst-case say worst case
yeah now if you write out this
commutator squared you see that you have
several terms four terms to be exact
some of them look like these time
ordered correlators i discussed
originally are close relatives of them
and after a few thermal timescales those
factorize and so we imagine that this
quantity C of T looks like you have two
such terms it looks like WWE and then
you get some new terms where you have VW
VW and so on and in fact you get twice
the real part of a new kind of
correlator this again is a thermal
expectation value
early time these are about the same you
cancel you get the small part of the
curve but for later time dis correlator
does something else notice that this is
out of time order 0 t 0 t these out of
time order correlators are a crucial
diagnostic because they determine this
commutator of chaos in these systems now
we can see inverting this curve that
this out of time order correlator starts
big to make this exactly cancel and then
if this characteristic time tails down
to zero when this is 0 this commutator
is its maximum you can see that this is
to WWE v we call the time at which this
happens a characteristic time for chaos
of the strong kind to set in we call it
t star the scrambling time yes yeah I'll
say just a question about it in fact
thats related to this first tail off is
exactly that yeah now an important piece
of progress and studying these is that
you can compute them using the bulk
using this picture of gravity
uh what 20 minutes in what do I have 10
more minutes yeah ok then i'm i'm not
going to be able to explain how you do
it but in these papers ok we illustrate
how you can actually compute these out
of time order correlators using things
in the bulk gravity the crucial thing is
that these out of time order correlators
are determined by a high-energy
collision these are thermal expectation
values it's good to purify to make them
expectation values in a pure state in
this double system of a left and the
right cft ok and so the dual picture of
that is this Penrose diagram that
Patrick drew this two-sided eternal
black hole and roughly speaking the
collision is a collision between pulses
going this way in the central region
near the horizons of this black hole
the strength of this collision is
determined and again we are in a
position where we can use some kinds of
gravitational perturbation theory
Newton's constant that determines the
strength of all gravitational
interactions times the energy of this
collision squared because i miss
berkeley alcohol this mandelstam s
that's the center of mass energy squared
in a collision it's not the entropy the
fact that this the amplitude for this
process grows with energy is a
characteristic of gravity gravity is a
process where interactions grow with
energy unlike gauge theories or vector
particles and this is crucial the onset
of chaos so what i will do is I'll try
to give you at least a heuristic for
what little s is what is the energy of
this collision
well roughly speaking this anymore
imagining inserting an operator here at
a time let's say an early time minus T
and we're asking what is the energy of
the pulse this operator emits let's say
in the reference frame determined by
this horizontal and vertical axis well
this picture has a symmetry if you move
time up in this direction and time down
in that direction it leaves the picture
unchanged this is the symmetry of the
thermal field double state where you
have energy on the left energy on the
right tensor product if you apply a
positive Hamiltonian to one factor and a
negative Hamiltonian for the other it
leaves the state unchanged that state
has a symmetry that's this symmetry well
you can see on this picture that however
let's go down in this direction it pulls
the pulse down further and further
toward this horizon in the middle of
this region you basically have ordinary
Minkowski space you take a little piece
of this geometry it looks like Minkowski
space here's a symmetry that if you act
with it more and more in Minkowski space
you happen to hit a light cone what is
the symmetry that if you act further and
further in Minkowski space you end up
with a rayon a light coat it's a Lorentz
boost further this time is an additive
parameter in the symmetry the additive
parameter of Lorentz boost is called the
rapidity and so this time plays the role
of the rapidity of Lawrence boosts well
the energy that's created by a boost of
Ruth's rapidity t is exponential in T so
the energy squared little s is equal to
e to the T and the right coefficients
beta is the natural time scale and
there's a 2 pi here basically because
things have to be periodic and imaginary
time with period beta
it is just to be clear the invariant
thing is that you've got this other
operator yes that's right and so I put
that in by asking for the energy in this
particular reference frame that's what
picked out that process with the other
operator in people's that's right that
that's correct and then I need a scale
here let's call it the temperature
squared so then this strength of the
collision becomes 1 over N squared the
number of degrees of freedom in this
gauge theory e to the 2 pi t over beta
and the temperatures let's let's ignore
them for a minute and so the effect of
these operators on each other is
proportional to this and we can ask when
does a term like this get to be of order
1 well this effect is order 1 at a
particular time let's call it the
scrambling time T star equals beta over
2 pi log and this is the characteristic
time at which this thing breaks away
from its early time value the fact that
this depends exponentially
Khattab who also did this calculation
characterized this exponential he said
we should think of this as Ali oppan off
exponent something increasing with time
and this says that if use Einstein
gravity the Lyapunov exponent is equal
to 2 pi
but we've recently been able to apply to
give very strong arguments for is that
in any thermal quantum system with a
large number of degrees of freedom
precise statements are contained in this
feat that this Li operative exponent is
less than or equal to its value in
gravity this argument doesn't use
gravity it's just a future of Columbia
but it says that this chaotic
development in assistant in a system
with many degrees of freedom can happen
no more quickly and in the system with a
black hole cool
so again we've been able to use the
power of gravity to actually compute
yeah and then motivated by this we've
been able to prove proven quotes but
give a strong argument for found that
says things happen so this is actually
again backing off to strategic questions
this seems like a very powerful
technique and using ideas from gage
gravity dualities to get inspiration
from them and then with those results go
back and try to make more general
statements that these may bound or that
these may suggest the structure of I'm
basically what I have five more minutes
okay yes we expect it to be bound you
want you want me to give a summary of
this argument there's a CFP who do I
mean you there's an argument that's
independent of gravity that establishes
this as a pound would you want me to
give a so maybe outline miss may be weak
or we can include it in the discussion
yeah all right but well okay I'll give
you I'll give you one statement but it's
it's very hard the crucial thing is you
have that is these correlators these out
of time correlators or a generalization
them are analytic in time
and if things were to decrease very
quickly is a function of real time it
means they have to oscillate very
quickly as a function of imaginary time
and that roughly speaking means that if
along let's say the real time access of
suitably defined correlator decreases if
you go a little bit up in am a journey
time it'll increase chaos doesn't like
to make things increase okay and so
putting those pieces together you
develop about ok that's the taste
well there's a precise statement that
dysfunction C of T behaves like that for
some you know for some for a while and
eventually etc yes the precise
statements are about a variant it's not
see of tea itself but a variant that
suitably smear but a variant of let's
say of these out of time warder
correlators stays like this for a long
time and then breaks away the one well
the one that's bounded is one that
naturally decreases okay okay but then
you have to pass this GS yes you can
directly compute these things that
decrease using GS using the collision
argue okay well let me then turn to to
some questions then as a way to to
ignite some discussion
so here's some questions
we have a bound that we have a strong
argument for motivated by gravity I
think this is actually the first one
bound in a thermal boundary theory that
we actually have a strong argument for
there should be others when are the
others in particular there's a very
famous conjecture of something related
to this the so-called viscosity to
entropy density bound of haughton stara
nets and song and they conjectured that
this is greater than or equal 1 over 4
pi the way this casa t works it's a very
curious quantity the bigger the
viscosity is the fewer the collisions
are so this is a statement again about
the frequency of collisions and in
particular if you process this this
means that there's a timescale T
collision if you will that's greater
than or equal to H bar over K Boltzmann
that's the temperature this bound if
processed accordingly says that there's
a timescale the Lyapunov time that's
always greater than or equal to 1 over 2
pi
so we see the emergence of a time scale
in these systems this natural time scale
you make out of each bar and Katie and
it seems very hard for a system to do
something dramatic untamed scale shorter
than that this is something that an
uncertainty principle argument would
yield given this this new progress here
it may be time to revisit this bound we
know it's violated by small amounts
order 1 over N but perhaps with a little
more work we can we can get a result
that actually applies so that's a
question and maybe there are the results
like this involving this time scale and
we now can establish precisely using
technology like this a second question
in classical chaos if you know that sort
of for anywhere you are let's say in
phase space that you have Lyapunov
behavior that phase space trajectories
separate exponentially which this is
evocative of then you know the system
does better things it's mixing its which
implies berga disa t it really amazed
the strongest criteria for chaos does
something like this happen in quantum
chaos does this kind of exponentially
growing behavior for general operators
does this imply that the system might
for instance in Bob a the so lambda L
does this imply the eigenstate
thermalization hypothesis or the
stronger definitions of scrambling that
exists that lets say any subsystem with
less than half the degrees of freedom
looks thermal to high accuracy is there
some wake from going to short time chaos
the longer time yeah
it's probably very difficult but it
would be interesting to know at a last
question for discussion i would say that
our understanding from the bulk geometry
of this T star time scale at some time I
should probably write it that T star a
log of the entropy of the system capital
s not mandelstam s I think we're getting
a pretty good understanding of this T
start the next time scale that we know
something about is the entropy time so
that's called a page time which is like
beta times the entropy of the system
for simple correlation functions this
time scale
this is a behavior like this if you look
let's say at V of T V of zero thermal
average it decays as I explained and it
keeps decaying all the way out to this
entropy time where it has a value e to
the minus some oh meghan is and in jeff
on general grounds if you have a finite
entropy system thinks King auf get
smaller than that at least in root means
square so then the thing starts
oscillating around what features of the
bulk are responsible for these
oscillation this is something to do with
the finite entropy of the system may be
related to the fact that this smooth
geometry actually has a green eNOS
telling you that the horizon actually
has a finite number of bits it up what
is the the picture there and usually in
physics if you can't have a full
understanding there's some hint you know
there's some hint happening here can you
make a first hint about what the
correction is to ordinary black hole
geometry that start responsible for
these Wiggles what is it and last
go down firewalls what does this all
have to do with firewalls in particular
at this time is this the diagnostic in
geometry all right that has to wait till
this afternoon I think there I'll stop
and we can continue talking about this
thank you yes yes so I mean it seems
that I 10 consider our systems I given a
number of customer appointment but not
like a company is that I still have I
still have some part of it which is any
it slightly restricted gives it's like I
can I got someone at ease any of you
sweetheart yo are just the questions is
that possible I mean it seems nothing
praveen me to have a summarization a
subset of the theory in which case i
will have the lambda L for some
operators but not for the concern well I
guess the question is are there are
there reasonable systems that do that
besides tensor product systems I mean
are there do you know of an example with
many degrees of freedom that actually
does that there are systems we say i
have three Alcovy 3l cuban say say i
have a well Kobey's I should real Cuban
so so so it's not completely solo but
you can reduce use the conserved
quantities to reduce it does it have
like a reasonable Hamiltonian or local
what system you mean
though I is that system strongly chaotic
though I don't know but there seems no
reason I mean grab my butt but I mean
the generalizations we have can't have
heart of the concern point is reduce our
degree of freedom but then the remaining
degrees of freedom are not solvable and
it doesn't seem very well so i don't i
just mean there is no reason for being
like this kind of thing well but that
would be interesting maybe that's what
one needs to do to make to make this
precise our experience in the
Hamiltonians we know about it this
doesn't happen very often although there
there's an important glitch in these
gauge gravity duels people have found
some solutions that seem to behave non
chaotically even though they have high
energy for a long time but but I i well
okay if you'll be that's that's what
this question is kind of about is how
often that happens is that highly non
generic if you apply a small
perturbation is that stable I me does it
have kam kind of stability or not very
big mathematical physics result on that
are almost approved yes which is in the
context of many body localization would
you listen to storage systems are
disordered systems breaking
translational invariance and so on you
have a stable non-organic face good find
it those weren't heavily open off
behavior at all that's right no I mean I
guess the point is yes it that but that
would be avoiding ETH which we knew as
possible in integral models but in a
very unstable way it was all actually
it's an unstable integral models I
thought there was like a am kind of
stability oh sorry in the cookie in the
thermodynamic limit but yes that's
that's correct in the thermodynamic
limit but there is yes good INRI for
example or something showing that there
must be it must be quite subtle with
systems to achieve the eth even if we
only consider stable systems yeah okay i
was giving myself this the strong power
of obtaining that the Lyapunov exponent
to get us a little bit of the way I
think that easily rules out those
examples so i guess i mean with extra
conserved quantities there will be
things that don't have any i think
that's right so maybe i should have
answered the
a better question well I guess gu be
clarity Picard about yeah I thought I
thought you mean some love no I want all
the operators to do this yeah okay so I
want all the operators have short time
just like the theorems in classical
chaos you have a phase space where
everything things strongly expand that's
where it's easy to prove good theorems
about chaos and the question is does
that exist here that's the question yeah
I should have given a sharper answer
thank you um yes this probably is a dumb
question so there are no dumb questions
here I was happy with you be surprised
how's happy that the two time
correlation of your operator V would
reach some kind of equilibrium yes a
thermalization time which is just the
temperature yes yep that's your here the
two-time correlations between distinct
operators V and W but to a to like VW
just a two-point function or four point
function maybe oh maybe four okay so
yeah this was where the T star yes
before that's a four point function how
much does that depend on your choice of
V and W I was I was imagining that you
know let's say B is basically you know
the value of this spin this projection
and W far far away far away in a local
system and we're less they going to
equilibrate toward a ferromagnetic state
right so at some point these guys are
going to be relaxed toward being
correlated yes the timescale for that is
clearly going to depend on the distance
between them so good word didn't show up
in your men yes I was quite high
deliberately alighted that an important
extension is to think about things
localized at different spatial points
then there will be a velocity something
like the liebe Robinson velocity that
tells you how long you have to wait for
this phenomenon to cydia yes there I
don't really see what the role
you know alia field exponent is I don't
see that that is a something that would
I don't see that is exponential behavior
i see well if you think about the liebe
Robinson bound actually you there is an
exponential growth in these commutator
'he's and it's balanced against some
exponential decay and something else and
that's where the liebe Robinson velocity
comes in so actually liebe Robinson does
have an exponentially growing part of
the story you have so many other paths
when you compute these commutator Xin
whatever it's called in in perturbation
theory when you expand out the
Hamiltonians you have many paths for the
terms of the hamiltonian to take and
they cause an exponential growth in the
if you look at the bounds there's an
exponential increasing part of time on
the right hand side of the bound and
that's that's closely related to this
very the locations of the operators
especially on this under boundaries here
or boundary flee yes you can and you can
compute that holographically let me
think well so so chaos one setting at
all until you have a let me think you
have an e to the T e to the minus X with
some coefficients and one over N squared
so if X is very large this will be the
two pi over beta coefficient and this
will be another coefficient I guess we
calm you in order to make this thing get
big or small it's like the case maybe
you have this rising T has to over whelm
this growing thing this decreasing thing
in X okay and so balancing those two you
find that there's a velocity you have to
have a certain multiple of T to
overwhelm this X suppose these
coefficients were the same you had you'd
have e to the t minus X 1 over N squared
when does that get order one it's when
to use of order X plus enough to
overwhelm this one over
squared and so this corresponds to a
velocity in the holographic limit in the
Einstein gravity limit you find this a
velocity I guess we called it the
butterfly of X velocity that's what one
over boy d over 2 D minus one where this
is the space-time this is right yeah
this is the space-time dimension of the
boundary field theory it's interesting
that the coefficients don't depend on
temperature for this so you'll find
actually that you have to wait a certain
amount of time before an extra time
other than the scrambling time if the
points are far away from each other the
thing has to propagate out and then
scramble just sits the clipper out
that's right it shifts the clip around
by an amount proportional to this
spatial time delay and so in fact
there's a picture of chaos spreading out
ballistically from a localized point so
then T star relates to the entropy so
that's measuring this be the the size of
this wave front which is coming past and
scrambling I mean well what one picture
is over this this amount of time we go
from you know pre thermalization to post
thermalization value well one way of
thinking about it here and it's
important is that each point you have a
lot of degrees of freedom n squared
degrees of freedom this is tied into
this mystery that the tensors you know
have very large index range that at
every point in a large n gauge theory
you have a lot of variables so you have
to sort of cause interactions among
those variables as well as between
adjacent points so two things have to
happen you have to kind of cause chaos
within the degrees of freedom at every
point that's really what I've been
talking about here and you have to
propagate chaos between neighboring
points both of those things have to
happen
yep sort of baby step towards to do you
know whether you're able to usefully
bound any higher order correlators like
in terms of this four point function
you've got a new timescale of hearing
when you went from the two-point
function on the floor mm-hmm but somehow
the hope is that you don't see much more
after that right that's a good question
um
um let me think there certainly are some
multi-point functions that we've been
able to study and they don't display new
timescales beyond this but whether there
is something else i'm not sure the
rigorous bad you're asking a real
question but a real bound I don't
actually know Douglas do you have a do
you have a have you thought about that
the only comment that you might make is
it in the bulk it's sort of clear the
more adding more of these operators and
so on you don't you don't get some
qualitatively new thing happening like
you did and gone from two to four
operators where you went when you
introduce this hyderi scattering trouble
with more operators you'll get you know
more complicated kinematics for a
scattering problem but the relevant
scales are the same but the kind of band
that you're familiar with these kind of
catchy Schwartz inequalities I don't
know whether they can said it might well
be possible to make some precise
statement yeah I just I just wanted to
add a question yes so is this uh I was
gonna get on my knees but I think I'll
stay standing up yes need to write it
I'll just second you can decide so so do
all do all conformal field theories that
have a large n limit and a large gap in
operator dimensions obey this bound in
other words on the list of properties
that conformal field theory needs to
have to have a gravity duel is this a
new element on the list or is it somehow
does it somehow follow from the other
things
that's a good question um
or saturate let's let me say century
century century
well there's things we know about it you
have to ask finer detail questions about
what you mean by a large gap okay if you
mean a gap of order string scale then we
know the answer is no there's a small
deviation from the bound that supported
them well if that's into the net string
scale right so so we I'm so into the one
quart you mean Planck scale plank in
plank the gap is playing yeah I think
there we have no reason to believe that
it will be saturated we have the reasons
that you know about which suggests that
it is saturated obviously true i mean it
could be that you there these are higher
energy states in the cft they don't
obviously have something to do is only
the few languages that this live example
means the the gap occurs at the other
end or all right and to some power yeah
but but but it's a power which is small
compared to N squared so it doesn't
obviously have anything to do with what
happens in these very excited states
with volume la entanglement I mean this
of court well you know the argument as
well as I do that it looks like the bulk
is described by an effective Einstein
gravity and in Einstein gravity the this
calculable calculation is as a line you
can wave your hands about modular
variants and imagine that somehow
there's some relationship between these
very high energy states and the spectrum
the low energies
yes I see what you mean i I don't know
an argument better than the one I just
know we have explicit examples that
would satisfy these things some of these
balls if you can make black holes yes
yes I think I would agree with that
intuition i don't i don't know of a
proof technique to help with that and of
course there are explicit examples the
what's the best example that doesn't
have string states the idiot know Vasili
I've won't that that well yeah inside
baseball yeah okay oh I decide what
understand the last constants I would
have thought one plus one spatial
dimension CFPs are basically integral
and they're not they are certainly not
integral the ones well not that I love
and you probably love are often interval
okay but they are not there exists I
mean there must be something wrong with
the ones that are integral because
they're clearly not going to saturate
that's right they won't they won't they
won't even have a Lyapunov behavior
condition do they violate of conjecture
number five is it that they don't have
the right gap in their scaling
dimensions so yes that's correct like
for instance integral systems have large
cairo algebra is that create states and
rather modest values of the conformal
wait they'll populate the gap thoroughly
but even something trivial you know and
i see models or something like that
that's got lots of stuff at looking for
my way this gap is a really says that
they're somehow that that's right in
particular it means there's nothing this
is a graph of scaling dimension I guess
not versus anything okay and the claim
is the only things you can have here
till of order n to the one quarter are
the stress tensor and it is there a
sense that interventions greater than
one that's kind of generic property of
CFDs cuz I don't know enough about
higher dimensional CMT's be this is a
large class that satisfies so it's not a
generic class is actually a very special
class okay and so I the ones that
actually would be scribed by pure
Einstein gravity in the bulk are rather
special for instance and this famous a
tough coupling parameter you would have
to take that parameter all the way
extraordinarily large to
to be in a situation with a large gap
you just threw darts at this line of a
tough coupling this is how a lot
stronger even than just saying large
central charge and things like that is
what it is much stronger than saying
large central charge it's much stronger
than that and you know the discussion is
morally speaking at saying which things
are described by Einstein gravity in the
bowl yes yes yes oscillation time yes we
think what have we say that because they
are some dominant saddle points of fun
gravity and it long time limit those
contributions might become proposed that
that argument has been explored and and
by in particular a bit of itchy and bar
bone have found serious problems in that
argument there's some way that that sub
sub leading saddle points in real time
is kind of not the right thing to do but
that that's kind of the question like
what is the right sort of you know first
correction that you there ma you know I
we've been around in physics long enough
to know that you know it's often a good
idea to look for the first correction to
some reference point and and we don't
know what it is and it's irritating that
we don't that particular thing though
doesn't I'm not people are not
optimistic about I think
alright so let's take a break and read
the main at eleven-thirty